another day another grim milestone in
this pandemic with the highest number of
deaths recorded
so far since covert 19 arrived on these
shores
it's worth just underlining what we're
talking about here each of these dots
here
show you the number of deaths announced
on any given day you can see the spring
last year there and you can see where we
are now and there you can see it
the highest dot of all 1325
deaths just announced it's worth saying
though while that is the highest of
those dots
when you look at when the deaths
actually occur it's a somewhat different
picture
it is a higher peak actually uh last
spring than we're seeing at the moment
we are still someway
below that but we are climbing gradually
and steadily it's a different kind of
shape but we are heading in that
direction and the concern is
we are going to continue to head in that
direction when you look at what's
happening in hospitals we've got a sense
here
of how this pandemic compares with
previous flu seasons these lines here
show you previous years
and what happened in terms of admissions
to hospitals and this is population
adjusted admissions to hospitals over
flu seasons in the previous
three years and now let's have a look at
what happened with covert 19. so that's
where we are at the moment you can see
it's a lot higher in terms of
admissions in england and when you look
at london in particular of course that
crisis in london hospitals well it's
much higher than any other part
of the country and despite that though
the reproduction rate the r number we're
told is still
relatively low in comparison to where it
was
last time around it's worth just digging
into this this shows you
uh what happened to the r number in the
early part of covert 19 up at about
three remember this is the reproduction
rate it's the idea
how many people you could potentially
pass the disease to if you have it and
it has climbed a little bit recently
but still that one to 1.4 according to
the latest estimate
it's a little bit below actually where
it was in the winter
yet cases are higher and that's because
we're starting from a higher base and
anything above one means
it is spreading exponentially around the
country and the concern is
that might well continue even though
there was a vaccination program we had
latest
documents out from sage and they are
concerned if we just kind of whizzed
through them
they are concerned about one thing in
particular i'm going to zoom in here and
we'll have a look at this bit where they
talk about the
effectiveness of the vaccine they say
that there could be reduced adherence
reduced adherence
uh could more of than offset the
benefits of vaccination by increasing
infection rates in short this is a race
at the moment between the vaccination
and this disease itself